dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly fajir when using
cryptography we'd like to safely
communicate over the Internet in the
presence of third parties to be able to
do this and many other important
applications we need random numbers but
what does it exactly mean that something
is random randomness is the lack of any
patterns and predictability people
usually use coin flips as random events
that is a coin flip really random if we
had a really smart physicist who can
model all the forces that act upon the
coin he would easily find out whether
it's going to be heads or tails strictly
speaking a coin flip is therefore not
random what about random numbers
generated with computers computers are a
collection of processing units that run
programs if one knows the program code
that generates the random numbers they
are not random anymore because it
doesn't happen by chance and it is
possible to predict john von neumann
famously said anyone who considers
arithmetic methods of producing random
digits is of course in a state of sin
for as has been pointed out several
times there is no such thing as a random
number there are only methods to produce
random numbers and a strict arithmetic
procedure of course is not such a method
some websites offer high-quality random
numbers that are generated from
atmospheric noise practically speaking
this of course sounds adequate enough if
someone wants to break the encryption of
our communications they would have to be
able to model the physics and initial
conditions of every single thunderbolt
which means processing millions of
discharges per day this is practically
impossible so it seems reasonable to say
that random events are considered random
because of our ignorance not because
they are strictly speaking unpredictable
you just need to be smart enough and the
notion of randomness fades away in the
light of your intelligence or so it
seemed for physicists for a long time
imagine if someone who has never heard
about magnetism would see many magnets
attracting each other and some
did magnet powder this person would most
definitely say it's magic happening
however if you know about magnetism you
know that things don't happen randomly
there are very simple laws that can
predict all this movement in this case
magnetic forces we can loosely call a
hidden variable so we have a phenomenon
that we cannot predict and we are keen
to say it's random in reality it is not
there is just a hidden variable that we
don't know of that is responsible for
this behavior we have the very same
phenomenon if we look inside of an atom
quantum level effects happen according
to the physics of extremely small things
and we again find behaviors that seem
completely random we know some of the
trends just like we know which roads in
our city are expected to have a huge
traffic jam every morning but we cannot
predict where every single individual
car is heading we have it the same way
with extremely small particles we are
keen to say that a behavior seems
completely random because nothing that
we know or measure would explain it
other people would immediately say wait
you don't know everything
maybe these quantum effects are not
random as there may be hidden things
hidden variables that you don't know of
which make up for the behavior we can't
just say this or that is random it is
much much more likely that our knowledge
is insufficient to predict what is
happening as electromagnetic forces
seemed magical to scientists a few
hundred years ago so is quantum
mechanics completely random or does it
only seem random it is probably one of
the most difficult questions ever asked
how can you find out that something you
measure that seems random is really
completely random and not just the act
of forces that you don't know of and
hold onto your chair because this is
going to blow your mind
a simple and intuitive statement of
Bell's Theorem states that no physical
theory of local hidden variables can
ever reproduce all of the predictions of
quantum mechanics
this means that he proved that the
behavior scientists experience in
quantum mechanics are really random they
cannot be explained by any theory you
could pass
make up simple one or complicated
doesn't matter this discovery is
absolutely insane
you can definitely prove that the crappy
theory someone quickly made up doesn't
explain a behavior but how can you prove
that it is completely impossible to
build such a theory that does no matter
how hard you try how smart you are you
can't do it this is such a mind-boggling
ly awesome theorem and please note that
we definitely lose out on some details
and generality because of the fact that
we use intuitive words to discuss these
results as opposed to the original
derivation with covariances between
measurements on our imaginary list of
the wonders of the world monuments
created not by the hands but the minds
of humans this should definitely be
among the best of them thanks for
watching and for your generous support
and I'll see you next time